[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend eineinhalb stunden lang hat
sich annalena baerbock hier im zdf eben
den fragen gestellt die menschen mit
unterschiedlichsten anliegen und quer
durch alle bevölkerungsschichten an sie
hatten so wie das auch armin laschet und
olaf scholz schon getan hatten solche
formate sind beliebt weil man die
kandidierenden im direkten austausch mit
dem wahl volk erleben kann chancen und
risiken und jetzt in dieser letzten alle
heißen wahlkampfphase ist der druck noch
mal besonders hoch auch für annalena
baerbock die aus schwindelerregenden
umfrage höhen einen krachenden absturz
erlebte und jetzt hoffen muss dass die
grünen auf den letzten metern noch mal
wieder zulegen über ihren auftritt
berichten bernd benthin und patricia
wiedemeier
sie tourt derzeit mit dem grünen
wahlkampf bus durchs ganze land ein
auftritt jagt den nächsten heute abend
nun berlin annalena baerbock stellte
sich anderthalb stunden den fragen von
rund 70 bürgern ob die grünen noch um
platz eins auf sieg spielen würde
nachdem sie in den umfragen jetzt auf
platz 3 liegen die einstiegsfrage bin
zutiefst davon überzeugt dass dieses
land deutlich mehr kann und dafür treten
wir grün an und dafür trete ich als
kanzlerkandidat form ist dann ging es
weiter natürlich mit dem urgrünen thema
klima
bis 2030 soll zum beispiel der kohle
ausstieg geschafft sein früher als
momentan vereinbart früher als 20 38
ist deutschland überhaupt in der lage
allein mit den maßnahmen zu wird sehr
oft auch propagiert und eben auch von
ihrer partei
allein in der lage das zu bewältigen ich
bezweifle das natürlich und sicherlich
viele auch wir haben eine riesenchance
als europäer mit klimaneutralität europa
als erster kontinent klimaneutral zu
machen natürlich mit allen eu
mitgliedsstaaten zusammen und der
deutsche kohle ausstieg ist dann im
zusammenspiel mit polen und tschechien
genau der weg dahin um funkerberg
verspricht eine gerechtere verteilung
von windrädern in deutschland mehr geld
für biobauern aber dass sich sofort
alles verändere das verspricht sie nicht
wie können sie das als klimaschutz
partei verantworten dass sie ein
wahlprogramm aufstellen was das 1,5 grad
ziel nicht befolgen wird wir dürfen beim
klimaschutz keine halben sachen mehr
machen sondern dass alles in die wege
leiten und das hat für mich priorität in
der nächsten bundesregierung
nächstes thema corona in der pandemie
stützten die grünen zu anfang den
regierungskurs mittlerweile übt vor
allen dingen immer wieder baerbock
deutliche kritik wie zu wenig werde für
die sicherheit der schulkinder getan wie
kriegen wir das hin die länder dazu zu
bringen endlich das geld in die hand zu
nehmen was notwendig ist wir müssen die
priorität auf bildung liegen und dann
hieß es von der bundesregierung der bund
ist dafür aber nicht zuständig ich halte
das für falsch und ich will dass der
bund in die verantwortung geht weil mit
blick auf die frage gelder an den
schulen wir brauchen einfach eine
verlässliche finanzierung in allen
schulen haben aber auch ihr holpriger
start in den wahlkampf war thema können
sie einen geschönten lebenslauf abgeben
und so zu tun als ob nichts gewesen wäre
ich habe in meinem lebenslauf
unterschiedliche mitgliedschaften
angegeben und das nicht alles
aktualisiert gehabt sondern das unter
eine sammel rubrik gestellt
mitgliedschaften und zum beispiel bei
greenpeace ist man kein mitglied sondern
fördermitglied und das habe ich dann
entsprechend korrigiert insgesamt
versprach sie vielen bürgern nach der
wahl bei ihnen vorbeizukommen
ausführlicher mit ihnen zu reden mal
sehen ob sie das auch wirklich einhalten
wird
dass man jetzt noch mal weiter
analysieren mit dem
politikwissenschaftler karl rudolf korte
sie sind ja stammgast bei uns wenn es
darum geht es um wahlsendungen und
ähnliches zu analysieren auch bei armin
laschet hallo und olaf scholz heute also
annalena baerbock vorneweg gefragt was
war so ihr eindruck welche strategie hat
sie worauf setzt sie jetzt in dieser
phase offensiver im vergleich zu den
anderen genauso souverän und fakten
kundig aber eine ganz andere generation
sie greift anders an auch durch das
alter also aufbruch zukunft dynamik mit
ihnen ein anderes verhältnis gesetzt das
war der größte unterschied für mich zu
den anderen beiden kandidaten
sind die grünen mit annalena baerbock in
einer fast kuriosen situationen also es
könnte sein dass sie mit dem besten
ergebnis ihrer geschichte in den
bundestag einziehen viel mehr
abgeordnete das ist ja mal eine große
leistung für eine partei dass sie auch
möglicherweise an der regierung
beteiligt sind mutmaßlich aber trotzdem
enttäuscht sind er kommt auf den maßstab
an was man an legt man kann sagen sie
sind in dieser legislaturperiode
eigentlich die strategischen
wettbewerbssieger auf den parteien markt
das ist jetzt erkennbar ob sich noch ein
paar prozent verlieren oder zu gewinnen
aus der kleinsten fraktion machen sie
nicht die größte aber eine sehr große
sich verdoppeln sich das ist ein gewinn
unser maßstab ist die annahme von
umfragen dass sie eben auch einige
monate vor den anderen parteien lagen
wir müssen vermutlich den maßstab
korrigieren aber die angriffs richtung
ist glaube ich klar eine größere
erzählung zu machen in die offensive zu
kommen das war heute auch thema mit
bündnispartnern übersetzungs helfer zu
werden und nicht nur im kleinen detail
sachfragen zu beantworten das ist ja
dass also eine erzählung auch ein
bisschen als führungs erzählung zu
intonieren und damit auch die
unterschiede in der gesellschaft sind
auch hier heute abend zum thema gemacht
worden sind nicht wegzudiskutieren
sondern sie zu übersetzen denn sie sagen
erzählungen man hat ein bisschen an
druck die erzählung verengt sich doch
jetzt wieder sehr auf das klimathema
eine zeit lang wollten sich die polen
hier eigentlich ein bisschen breiter
aufstellen ja die der rettung eine
richtung zu geben hatte viele facetten
und unter corona bedingungen das hat ja
auch ein bisschen gegen die grünen erst
mal gespielt dass diese auf bugs
veränderungsdynamik eingebremst worden
ist und die veränderung müdigkeit
einsetzt das ist etwas was ihnen
eigentlich gegen sie spielt und die
defensive bringt andererseits so ein
realitäts demut die wenn der korona
phase alle selbst erlebt haben dass wir
nicht her der natur sind spielt den
grünen zu aber die flut ging hier
eigentlich nicht viel geholfen deine art
hall und real weil sie letztlich krisen
lotsen belohnt und damit auch das
management von krisen sie sind zwar in
vielen bundesländern mit am regieren in
10 genau aber die sichtbarkeit als
krisen lotsen hatten natürlich andere
man noch mal zurück denkt an die zahlen
corona hin oder her im mai lagen die
grünen bei um zumindest ein
politbarometer bei unfassbaren 26
prozent also da war das auch nicht
kurios und kanzlerkandidatin auszurufen
jetzt im nachhinein denkt man das rennen
ist wahrscheinlich für sie gelaufen oder
gar nicht gelaufen wenn sie mitregieren
das ist natürlich auch schon ein erfolg
aber sie hatten sich definiert durch das
andere etwas anders sein sind in die
falle gegangen der anderen parteien auch
ein kanzler kandidaten aufzustellen
während beide noch habeck und werber
gleichermaßen im rennen werden wir
neugierig darauf wie sie über die
ziellinie laufen und das wäre viel
raffinierter gewesen als auf einen zu
verhängen so haben sie auch mit bücher
schreiben alles gemacht wie andere aber
das war der scham anders zu sein das ist
interessant also dann eben doch die alte
klassische grüne doppelspitze darauf
weiter zu setzen aber dann hätte sie
nicht mit diesem training teilgenommen
man ist dann halt die kleinere punkte
müssen auch die medien vielleicht eine
neue logik an den tag legen in einer
wettbewerbssituation die eben diesmal zu
einem unikat wahl an historischen wahl
führt wahrscheinlicher mit zwei
verschiedenen kanzler möglichkeiten am
wahlabend wir reden am sonntag nach dem
nächsten training noch mal seit langen
und erstmal schon mal vielen dank für
die analyse
als in hagen gestern abend die polizei
zu einem großeinsatz ausrückte und die
dortige synagoge umstellte kamen sofort
schlimme erinnerungen hoch der anschlag
in halle vor zwei jahren war ja auch am
jom kippur feiertag in halle war ist ein
deutscher rechtsextremist der versuchte
während des gottesdienstes in die
synagoge einzudringen später erschoss
eine passantin und den gast einer
imbissstube
jetzt in hagen steht ein 16 jähriger
syrer im verdacht einen islamistischen
anschlag geplant zu haben ein
ausländischer geheimdienst habe darauf
ernst zu nehmende und konkrete hinweise
gegeben erklärte heute der nordrhein
westfälische innenminister
was bislang überhaupt bekannt ist fast
dalian tag zusammen
wohnungsdurchsuchung am frühen morgen
spezialeinheiten der polizei führen
einen von vier männern ab im fokus der
ermittler ein 16 jähriger hagener mit
syrische staatsbürgerschaft was die
täter konkret vorgehabt haben sollen ist
jetzt auch gegenstand der ermittlungen
dafür sind heute unter anderem mehrere
objekte im stadtgebiet in hagen
durchsucht worden die polizei hatte am
vorabend die synagoge in der innenstadt
weiträumig gesperrt ein am abend
geplanter gottesdienst zum höchsten
jüdischen feiertag war abgesagt worden
auslöser war ein tipp eines
ausländischen geheimdienstes an die
deutschen sicherheitsbehörden die vor
dem mutmaßlichen islamisten gewarnt
hatten per chat soll sich der 16-jährige
über einen sprengstoff anschlag auf die
synagoge unterhalten haben
der hinweis ließ rückschlüsse auf ein
islamistisch motivierte bedrohungslage
zu konkret heißt übrigens klare tatzeit
tat und täter waren benannt
parteiübergreifende betroffenheit
ministerpräsident laschet versprach am
rande einer wahlkampfveranstaltung in
bremen aufklärung wir haben dem
zentralrat der juden und den jüdinnen
und juden übermittelt dass wir alles tun
um die sicherheit jüdischen lebens in
deutschland zu garantieren und wir
werden alles tun um aufzuklären welche
netzwerke möglicherweise hinter diesem
anschlag standen der antisemitismus
beauftragte spricht von einer erhöhten
bedrohungslage für jüdinnen und juden in
deutschland nach dem attentat von halle
kann die tödliche dimension von
antisemitismus von niemandem mehr
verneint werden und auch der vorfall
gestern hat gezeigt wie schnell sich die
täter radikalisieren und eine ganz
konkrete tödliche gefahr darstellen die
generalstaatsanwaltschaft düsseldorf
ermittelt nun wegen des verdachts der
vorbereitung einer schweren
staatsgefährdenden gewalttat
in sachsen anhalt war heute
ministerpräsidenten wahl die nicht ganz
so lief wie sich reiner haseloff das
wohl gewünscht hätte damit beginnen die
nachrichten von heinz wolf im ersten
wahlgang fehlten reiner haseloff eine
stimme gewählt wurde er erst im zweiten
wahlgang damit geht haseloff gut drei
monate nach der landtagswahl in
sachsen-anhalt in seine dritte
amtsperiode der 67 jährige cdu politiker
erhielt schließlich 53 der 97 gültigen
stimmen über 56 abgeordnete verfügt
haseloffs koalition aus cdu spd und fdp
der tarifstreit zwischen der deutschen
bahn und der lokführergewerkschaft gdl
ist beigelegt somit sind weitere streiks
vom tisch beide seiten haben sich auf
eine lohnerhöhung von insgesamt 3,3
prozent und die zahlung von 2 corona
prämien geeinigt außerdem hat die gdl in
die geplante umstrukturierung der
betrieblichen altersvorsorge
eingewilligt der neue tarifvertrag gilt
für 32 monate
zur corona situation in deutschland und
zu den aktuellen zahlen das robert koch
institut meldet 12
1925 neuinfektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden
das sind 2506 weniger als vergangenen
donnerstag
68 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incident sinkt leicht auf 76,3
531 weitere corona infizierte mussten
seit gestern ins krankenhaus damit liegt
die hospitalisierung rate bei
1,87
bundeskanzlerin merkel und frankreichs
staatschef makro stehen weiterhin zu
einem engen deutsch französischen
vorgehen in internationalen fragen bei
einem treffen heute abend in paris
wollten sie unter anderem über die lage
in afghanistan sprechen und auch über
lehren dass folgenreichen truppenabzugs
aus dem land außerdem soll es um themen
der europäischen union wird für den
klimaschutz team
die usa großbritannien und australien
haben einen sicherheitspakt für den
indopazifik raum angekündigt vor allem
scheint dieser sich gegen die
militärische bedrohung durch china zu
richten us präsident biden sprach von
einer sich rasch entwickelnden bedrohung
man wolle unter anderem australien beim
bau von nuklear betriebene nur boden
helfen die chinesische regierung nannte
diese allianz eine gefährdung für den
regionalen frieden
dass die usa im indopazifik jetzt noch
mal so deutlich flagge zeigen könnte
indirekt auch mit dem ende des
afghanistan-einsatzes zusammenhängen der
chaotisch abzug dort hat im
indopazifischen raum nämlich große
ängste ausgelöst taiwan etwa fragt sich
ob auf die amerikaner als schutzmacht
noch verlass ist die afghanen jedenfalls
sind nun weitgehend auf sich selbst
gestellt das land ist praktisch ein
sicherheitsvakuum mit allen konsequenzen
die das auch für die nachbarländer hat
unsere reporterin susanne santina ist im
grenzgebiet zwischen afghanistan und
pakistan unterwegs und beobachtet wie
sich dort die lage für flüchtende
verschärft
die taliban auf afghanischer seite haben
sich heute verstärkt noch immer kommen
tausende afghanische flüchtlinge über
den grenzübergang torkham nach pakistan
aber es gibt weiter keine generelle lisa
nur noch ausnahmegenehmigungen etwas für
kranke oder solche die in ein anderes
land weiterreisen dürfen
jeden tag töten taliban frauen viele
menschen es gibt dort keine sicherheit
mehr
wir können dort nicht weiter lernen er
zur schule gehen
viele die es über die grenze geschafft
haben kommen erstmal in pensionen in
islamabad unter nick mohammad erzählt
uns bewegt dass die taliban aus rache
weil er als polizist für die vorherige
regierung gearbeitet habe zwei seiner
kinder ermordet haben ich habe sie
angefleht
behandeln sie uns
deswegen möchte ich mit meiner familie
so bald wie möglich
das wollen viele wissen aber nicht wie
ein visum für ein anderes land hätten
sie nicht sagt auch mohammad armut der
drei tage nach der machtübernahme der
taliban mit seiner familie nach pakistan
floh damals seien die kontrollen an der
grenze nicht zu streng gewesen
die menschen im park ist das staffel
gedanken sind in sicherheit aber wir
haben nichts und wir wissen nicht wie es
weitergehen soll
mohammad reza waren kabul student die
taliban hätten seine zukunftspläne
zunichte gemacht
dann haben die menschen auch keine
gefühle für sie wollen wir uns nichts zu
sagen haben sehr viel spreche nicht gut
wir hören uns in islamabad um viele
pakistani zeigen sich tatsächlich
kritisch
wir haben unsere grenzen geöffnet und
ohne kontrolle und mars sind afghanen
hier reingekommen wir wissen aus
erfahrung dass sich auch terroristen
unter die flüchtlinge mischen
sie sind unsere nachbarn lagen zwischen
geschwistern in der aktuellen situation
müssen wir ihnen helfen aber andere
länder sollten was auch
die regierung sollte sie rauschgift und
afghanen krieges von uns essen und
unterkunft alles und was bekommen wir
mit terrorismus
und vier millionen afghanische
flüchtlinge leben in pakistan schon seit
jahrzehnten viele immer noch in
flüchtlingslagern wie hier bei xaver
hier im grenzgebiet kommt es immer
wieder zu tödlichen auseinandersetzungen
zwischen taliban und pakistanischen
soldaten
im zdf interview zeigt sich der
innenminister des landes verärgert über
die vielfache kritik pakistan würde
islamistische terroristen protegieren
wir haben viele streitkräfte verloren in
den letzten jahrzehnten insgesamt 85.000
menschen leben in diesem konflikt mit
das ganze im kampf gegen terrorismus wie
viele opfer wir die welt ein dorf und
pakistan hat großes interesse an einem
stabilen afghanistan auch unter den
taliban und vor allem eine neue
flüchtlingswelle zu verhindern
die umstrittene ostsee-pipeline nord
stream 2 ist fertiggestellt
sehr zum missfallen ihrer vielen
kritikern
trotzdem 2 verläuft
1230 kilometer durch die ostsee von der
russischen küste nach deutschland nahe
greifswald und wie schon bei nord stream
ein vlies das russische gas damit nicht
mehr über land bisherigen transitländern
wie der ukraine entgehen dadurch
einnahmen auf dem boden der ostsee
wurden insgesamt
200.000 solcher beton ummantelte
stahlrohr stücke verlegt
welche neue pipeline kann die gleiche
menge gas fließen die durch die schon
bestehende nord stream eins nämlich
jeweils 55 milliarden kubikmeter
jährlich damit könnte deutschland seinen
jahresverbrauch an erdgas allein durch
die nord stream pipeline zu beziehen
kritik an dem projekt kommt nicht nur
von der ukraine und anderen
osteuropäischen ländern auch die usa
protestierten gegen das projekt und
umweltschützer versuchen weiterhin es zu
stoppen aber wäre das überhaupt noch
möglich
der frage ist andreas kienast
nachgegangen
als das rohr nummer 200
1858 das verlegeschiff in der ostsee
erreicht ist kein politiker kein
unternehmens boss und keine unabhängige
presse da ein kameramann der
projektgesellschaft filmt wie das letzte
das allerletzte stück nord stream zwei
verschweißt wird und die anwesenden
arbeiter in jubel ausbrechen
[Applaus]
vorsichtshalber zwei malen
mit nord stream zwei hinterlässt
kanzlerin merkel 1200 kilometer ärger
vor allem für osteuropa litauens
präsidentin aus da erinnert heute bei
seinem abschiedsbesuch daran dass die eu
klimafreundlicher unabhängiger und auf
dem binnenmarkt stärker werden will ich
glaube die verwirklichung des berners
co2 führt uns an die seite oder sogar
rückwärts von diesen zielen noch maximal
vier monate zeit haben deutsche behörden
um den betrieb von nord stream zwei zu
zertifizieren oder nicht von den
pipeline gegner setzen vor allem die
grünen darauf dass die erdgasleitung so
noch zu stoppen ist zu spät sagt
wolfgang peters der selbst mehrere
milliarden euro verfahren gegen gazprom
geführt hat verweigern sei rechtlich
nicht möglich wenn man ist doch tut da
führe ich mal das beispiel des
atomausstiegs an dann hat das zur folge
milliardenschwere entschädigung wegen
den eigenes gleichen eingriffs ob wir
das wollen ist ja wohl sehr die frage
wenn das erdgas strömt unter der ostsee
fürchtet vor allem die ukraine
angreifbar zu sein weil ihr gegner
russland dann keine rücksicht mehr
nehmen muss auf seine land leitungen
deshalb versuchen die pipeline
befürworter um merkel russland auf einen
langfristigen transit durch die ukraine
festzulegen und deshalb fragen die
pipeline gegner was wenn russland sein
wort bricht
ein pipeline ist das ist auch dort
vielleicht gashahn man kann gashahn
zudrehen nord stream zwei abschalten
falls russland der ukraine schadet das
ist auch die position der
kanzlerkandidaten scholz spd und laschet
cdu sie ist vorsichtig gesagt umstritten
ich halte es für ein rechtswidriges
wolkenkuckucksheim wir sind ja nicht im
dschungelcamp sondern in einem
rechtsstaat da gilt die sogenannte rule
of law und wenn alle genehmigungen
erteilt sind dann kann ich nicht
willkürlich eine pipeline an und
abschalten noch in diesem jahr
vielleicht schon im oktober will gazprom
das erste gas durch nord stream zwei
leiten und wer immer in deutschland an
die macht kommt dürfte nicht mächtig
genug sein es aufzuhalten
so und jetzt nochmal eins mit anderen
meldungen nach jahrelangen ermittlungen
und zwei verschiebungen wegen der korona
pandemie hat nun heute vor dem
landgericht braunschweig der
strafprozess gegen vier ehemalige vw
führungskräfte begonnen von der börse in
frankfurt aus hat für uns valerie haller
den prozessauftakt beobachtet worum ging
es an tag 1 heute wurde die
anklageschrift verlesen und die hatte es
in sich die staatsanwaltschaft wirft den
angeklagten unter anderem gewerbs und
bandenmäßigen betrug vor überraschend
war der richter hat einige punkte sogar
noch verschärft die angeklagten seien
nicht mittäter sondern nebentäter
bedeutet mehr eigenverantwortung und
möglicherweise ein höheres strafmaß
wer was wusste und wer was zu
verantworten hat das will der prozess
nun klären der lange auf sich warten
ließ sechs jahre ermittlungen zwei mal
verschoben müssen sich erstmals führende
vw mitarbeiter verantworten ihnen drohen
strafen von bis zu zehn jahren gefängnis
der skandal flog in den usa auf damals
wurde bekannt dass vw im großen stil
eine betrug software eingesetzt hatte
auf dem prüfstand waren die autos sauber
auf der straße stießen sie massenhaft
stickoxid aus der prozess startet ohne
ex vw chef winterkorn ballack lang ist
und nicht verhandlungsfähig wurde sein
verfahren auf später verschoben die
vw-aktie hat den skandal gut weggesteckt
seit 2006 ein starkes comeback die
wiedergutmachung kostete volkswagen mehr
als 32 milliarden euro dennoch hat der
konzern den skandal weitgehend hinter
sich gelassen volkswagen steuert nun
voll auf kurs und listen und größter
automobilhersteller der welt die
verhandlung aber wird sich noch
hinziehen 130 prozesstage sind angesetzt
weil er wir haben vielen dank
facebook hat knapp 150 konnten und
gruppen auf seinen plattformen gelöscht
die der internetkonzern der umstrittenen
querdenker bewegung zuordnet es sei
weltweit die erste gezielte aktion die
sich gegen eine gruppierung richte die
eine koordinierte schädigung der
gesellschaft betreibe so ein facebook
sicherheitsmanager dazu gehörten die
veröffentlichung von
gesundheitsbezogenen falschinformationen
hassreden und anstiftung zur gewalt
ein ergebnis vom fußball aus der uefa
europa conference liegt am ersten
gruppenspieltag verlor union berlin am
abend bei slavia prag eins zu drei
in köln wird zur stunde der deutsche
fernsehpreis verliehen als beste
dokumentation wurde die zdf koproduktion
schwarze adler ausgezeichnet auch zdf
talker markus lanz und fernsehgarten
gastgeberin andré aktive bekamen preise
ebenso wie hape kerkeling der komiker
schauspieler und buchautor wurde mit dem
ehrenpreis der stifter ausgezeichnet
preise gab es insgesamt in 28 kategorien
unter anderem für jan böhmermann
zdf-magazin dafür bestes buch und beste
ausstattung
so sieht der wüstenplanet arag es in der
verfilmung aus und wer die geschichte
nicht kennt der wüstenplanet
beziehungsweise im original dom war ein
bahnbrechendes science fiction epos der
60er jahren die romane wurden
weltbestseller das schreibt natürlich
eigentlich nach kino aller star wars
eine verfüllung gab es auch schon mal
wie war aber kein erfolg und jetzt ein
neuer anlauf mit großen blockbuster
geschirmt und vielleicht passt der film
diesmal besser in die zeit denn er hat
alle themen die gerade hochaktuell sind
heute war von ihrer annette hilsenbeck
berichtet
ein planet ist es so schön wenn die
sonne tief steht
wenn sie über dem sand schwebt kann man
das eis in der luft sehen spice ist der
super rohstoff arag ist den
wüstenplaneten
nachdem das ganze universum wird der
intergalaktisches reisen möglich macht
wegen dem kriege geführt dass folgt der
freeman vertrieben der planet zerstört
wird
der verwüsten unser land vor unseren
augen
paulat redis gespielt von hollywood
shootingstar thematisch armee landet mit
seiner familie auf arag ist das
herrscherhaus soll den friedlichen abbau
von spies übernehmen doch böse mächte
greifen sie an
wir fahren hin zur paul flieht gemeinsam
mit seiner mutter in die wüste von thun
ein überlebenskampf beginnt die vorlage
der science fiction bestseller von frank
herbert aus dem jahr 1965 ein stoff der
lange auf seine zeit gewartet hat
die menschen mit dem extrem klima
umgehen was menschen dem klima antun nur
um natürliche ressourcen auszubeuten um
die auswirkungen eines extremen
kapitalismus
ich hatte das gefühl dass dies alles
traurigerweise räumt ist viel relevanter
geworden ist
am komplexen universum das science
fiction autor herbert in seinem epos
schuf scheiterten schon einige
filmschaffende wilm es gibt wie beim
computer spielt die story zu anfang
dicht erzählt vor und setzt dann die
vorlage in hypnotisierende bilder um von
gigantischen sand würmern die von
rhythmus angezogen alles verschlingen
nur wer wie das einheimische folgt der
freeman den rhythmus unterbricht dinge
neu denkt entkommt
eine stil anzug ist ein hocheffizientes
filtersystem
selbst so frühe morgen würden sie
ohnehin keine zwei stunden überleben
auch wenn es darum geht der hitze zu
trotzen mit des dil anzügen die schmeißt
zu trinkwasser recycle klimaschutz seit
dem dreh für die schauspieler noch
wichtiger
wir haben ja dann in der wüste gedreht
mit diesen sogenannten destel anzügen
und es hat total sinn gemacht zu
verstehen dass du in der nahen zukunft
tatsächlich so was tragen muss
wenn wir so weitermachen wie wir es
jetzt tun und weiterhin die klimakrise
verleugnen so wird es werden
ein film der fridays for future
generation mit einer menschenfeindlichen
welt die man nicht selbst erleben möchte
der zugleich atemlos macht mit einer
sager von kampf liebe und heldentum
die junge generation und ihrer
zukunftsfragen hat gleich auch maybrit
illner im blick in ihrer
diskussionsrunde ist heute ausdrücklich
die junge politik generation zu gast und
um 0.30 meldet sich dann gundula gause
mit unserem heute-journal update es
morgen auf wiedersehen wieder sinn
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter im süden
deutschlands lässt der regen allmählich
nach das liegt daran dass es tief über
uns allmählich nach osten zieht aber es
lenkt aus dem norden etwas kühlere luft
und da sind wolken dabei schauer und
sogar gewitter anfangs der nacht also im
norden mit blitz und donner ansonsten
gibt es viele wolken im osten und nach
westen hin bildet sich nebel ähnlich
auch richtung oberrhein an den alpen
regnet es noch die temperaturen ganz im
westen dann um 8 grad einstellig kühl
auch nach süden gibt es acht bis neun
grad teilweise also recht kühle auch
dort 14 grad zum beispiel an der ostsee
ja und morgen nach westen und süden viel
sonnenschein ansonsten in den östlichen
landesteilen bis zur ostsee hoch viele
wolken und regen einzelne schauer sind
auch über den mittelgebirgen möglich und
das bei höchsten temperaturen von 22
grad am niederrhein und auch am oberen
22 grad richtung rhein main 21 und
relativ kühl hier kommt eben die kühlere
luft an richtung ostsee mit 16 grad der
blick auf die nächsten tage am samstag
gibt es im osten noch viele wolken und
regen ansonsten lockert es vor allem
nach westen hin auf bei 16 bis 24 grad
am sonntag dann vor allem im süden nass
mit regen bei 15 bis 21 grad und montag
kühler bei 14 bis 20 grad aber großteils
trocken damit ein schöner abend